الشمال هو السوري مشتعل اذا جهه الفاعلات
كثيره الطرف الاول اساسي طبعا تركيا تقصف
مواقع تابعه للمسلحين الاكراد وتهددو
باجتياح البري الطرف الثاني روسيا ارسلت
تعزيزات عسكريه لمناطق تسيطر عليها القوات
الكرديه وقوات النظام السوري في حلب اما
لوقف او تاخير العمليه التركيه بحسب
المرصد السوري طرفون ثالث التحالف الدولي
بقياده واشنطن استانف اليوم دوريته
المعتاده في مناطق سيطره الاكراد بعدما تم
تقليصها من القوات سوريا الديمقراطيه او
ما يعرف بقصد طرفا رابع قصد التي اوقفت
اليوم ايضا جميع عمليات مكافحه الارهاب
المشتركه مع التحالف وطلبت من روسيا
التدخل لدى انقره وهنا يظهر توتر اعتدنا
رؤيته بين انقره وواشنطن الاخيره طلبت
الاولى باعاده تقييم خطوط العمليات البريه
المحتمله
انقره يا حفه وعشان على الوفاء
بالالتزامات ما هي بحسب وزير الدفاع
التركي الكف عن تصليح مجموعات مسلحه
[موسيقى]